so anna i was talking to uh shamir
anderson a couple of days ago and we
started talking about lizzo
and he said he has you to thank for
introducing him to her music
i uh okay so i think i forgot that or i
yeah i heard that kind of during press
again and i was like
oh that's right i completely forgot
about that that makes me feel very cool
because i feel like shamir is like very
like
up on music stuff and yeah we filmed
this a couple years ago and
i'm just yeah it makes me feel very cool
that i like introducing no he's telling
everybody that you introduced him
for music so there you go yeah you can
own that one um
so just before we get into the movie is
there a song right now in your playlist
that you're obsessed with what do you
think will be like the song this summer
oh um gosh uh i mean
i feel like uh uh
olivia rodrigo like her like everything
she keeps putting out i'm like why
why are you why are you doing this to me
young lady like why are
like how are you so young and you're
talking about me
like how are you talking about all of us
how are you doing it i don't care for it
it's black magic
that's amazing it's so true though just
it's in the field especially in the car
you're like
all right
that's amazing well you're so great in
this movie um
so i want to know like if you were on a
space mission for two years
who do you think you would miss the most
oh man
um oh i don't know
uh i feel like um
the like the pitch perfect gang they're
like very good with advice
so i feel like it's not like i would
like miss them like on the daily
because we don't talk all the time but
like yeah i do feel like when i have a
problem there's like you know 10 women i
can like outsource
advice to that would be you know and
sure if i'm on a space mission it might
be like oh how do i fix this oxygen tank
and they might not know the answer but
i'd like to try
yeah that's good i like that um so if
you could pick
any celebrity to be on a two-year space
mission with
who would you pick um
gosh uh like i feel like somebody
funny oh but then i'm like oh would you
get annoyed with that
i mean honestly like it i'm this sounds
like a cop-out answer but it's not like
daniel day kim
who's in you know the movie with me like
he's just like
such a soothing presence to be around
because i was just like well who would
not get on my nerves and daniel
uh is like just he's still like
thoughtful and calming like there's just
something about him that's
um like very very relaxing feels like i
can't do that for two years
oh i love that so much so not shamier oh
no shamier's great and tony's great but
you know daniel's his dad he's got a
quality what can i say
i love that um so what was it about this
script and this character that you knew
you just needed to be a part of
um i mean i first of all like the silly
answer
is that i got to be a space doctor um so
that makes me feel like
very smart because not only am i an
astronaut like i'm
i'm a doctor
uh but uh you know i read this script
and it's so like
lean you know it's basically just like
there's four people in a lifeboat
and there's only enough resources for
three and like what do you do in that
situation
um and i saw joe the writer director i
saw his other film arctic
which is again like about just one man
trapped in the arctic trying to survive
and i was kind of expecting it to be
like
homework or something you know like i
was expecting it to be kind of like a
slog to get through
and instead i'm like in front of the tv
like on my feet like screaming like go
here go there like
you know it's so compelling and i think
like somebody who can turn
the story of a man alone in the arctic
into something that
that you're so invested in i think you
know that's the person that you
you know wanna you wanna tell the story
of four people trapped in space
yeah absolutely well congrats on the
film you're so much fun to talk it's my
first time interviewing you you're great
thank you yes so nice and yeah congrats
on the film i think everyone's gonna
love it
oh thank you so much